>>Female Presenter: Hello everyone.
I'm Winnie Lam.
It is my absolute honor to welcome Laura Arrillaga-Andreessen
to Google today who's gonna talk to us about
her new book, Giving 2.0.
Laura is the founder and chairman of the Stanford
Center on Philanthropy and Civil Society.
She's also founder, former chairman, and chairman
emeritus of the Silicon Valley Social Venture
Fund.
She teaches philanthropy at Stanford University
and at the Graduate School of Business.
It is my absolute honor to welcome her to
Google today to talk about her new book.
So without further ado please give a really
warm welcome to Laura Arrillaga-Andreessen.
[applause]
>>Laura Arrillaga-Andreessen: Thank you Winnie.
I'm so happy to be here.
Thank you all so much for taking the time
out of your chaotic schedules to join us here
today.
As I was prepping for this event, I went onto
the Google Authors site and was watching many
of the different presentations: extraordinary
politicians, extraordinary business leaders,
extraordinary academics, extraordinary philanthropists.
And there was one session that I watched in
particular that I wanted to draw attention
to because I think there are so many similarities
between me and this individual who is of course,
it goes without saying, Lady Gaga.
We have so much in common.
As you can see both of our maiden names end
with aga --
[laughter]
which is important.
If you Google Lady Gaga, there are about almost
500 million search results and if you Google
Laura Arrillaga-Andreessen there are almost
500 million less search results.
[laughter]
Additionally we both wore black mini dresses
to our Google talks which I think is very
important.
And additionally Lady Gaga was selected as
one of Time's most influential people in the
world and I read that issue.
[laughter]
But on a serious note, the one thing, the
one thing that Lady Gaga and I do have in
common is that we both have philanthropic
foundations and we are both fiercely committed
to access to opportunity and equality for
all.
And that is really the core purpose of the
work that I'm doing in philanthropy and my
inspiration for creating Giving 2.0.
[pause]
In each of our lives, we have these moments,
whether it is a disturbing article that we
read in a magazine about the state of public
education here in this country, whether it
is a personal experience we've had perhaps
having access to knowledge through our public
library as a child, or well I guess that was
true for my generation but perhaps not true
for the generation of every single person
in this room.
Or being the beneficiary of somebody else's
generosity like through a college scholarship
or it could be something that we learn about
in the world that horrifies us, that upsets
us such as famine or abuses to women and children
in a particular country or simply not having
freedom of expression.
But each of us has these experiences that
inspire us to realize that there is this whole
world outside of ourselves.
And these experiences inspire us to want to
reprioritize and to want to make a change
and to start living in service of others;
to give.
And for me my giving story began with my parents.
I am extraordinarily blessed to be the daughter
of two amazing philanthropists.
My father, John Arrillaga, Senior has dedicated
easily upwards of half of his time and financial
resources over the last two decades to his
philanthropic work.
But in particular I want to tell you about
my late mother, Frances Arrillaga.
This is Frances.
She was my best friend and my soul mate.
She was filled with a radiant grace and generosity
and she expressed her generosity in how she
chose to live her life every day.
During the last two decades of her life, she
sat on dozens of non-profit boards, she co-founded
two non-profits, she ran our family foundation,
but most importantly she was an extraordinary
community volunteer.
She is my role model.
It's probably not surprising that this woman
birthed a daughter who also shares the giving
gene along with, as you can see from this
photo, a lifelong love of wearing mini dresses
--
[laughter]
starting at age two, critically important.
But it was the giving gene that she gave me
that was activated at a very specific time
in my life.
It happened in 1993.
I'd just graduated from Stanford, I was working
at a really exciting high tech company here
in the Valley that unfortunately was not Google,
and I had just been accepted to Stanford Graduate
School of Business.
All of my dreams were coming true.
Three weeks later we found out that my mother
had cancer.
That day I quit my job and I deferred business
school and I stayed at home and became her
primary caregiver.
And this was a journey that lead me for the
20 months during her illness, prior to her
passing, to understand for the very first
time what human suffering was, and to live
for the very first time completely in service
of another human being.
And that was the most profound, meaningful
experience of my life.
And I realized during this time of essentially
becoming a mother to my own mother in her
time of greatest need that the very purpose
for my life was to live in service of others.
And ultimately, ideally was to help other
people understand ways of giving that can
be deeply meaningful not only to the organizations
and people that each of us aspires to help,
but also deeply meaningful to ourselves.
[sound of pages being turned]
[pause]
So how many people here in this room find
giving deeply meaningful?
How many people find that giving makes you
happy?
If giving makes you happy clap your hands.
[clapping]
Clap your hands.
Thank you so much.
Happy Holidays and I'll --
[laughter]
be signing books in the back.
Okay, so every single person in this room
is a giver; not only is a giver, but you give
joyfully.
How many people in this room self identify
as a philanthropist?
Raise your hand.
[pause]
Okay, so only a handful of people in this
room self identify as philanthropists, yet
every single person in this room gives.
That's an interesting disparity.
And I think I know why that is the case.
Because you might feel like self identifying
as a philanthropist is too self promotional
or you do not fit the mold, or you do not
have enough money to consider yourself a philanthropist.
For me, I believe the very idea of what a
philanthropist is is ripe to democratized.
Philanthropy actually derives from the Greek
word philanthropis which means love for human
kind.
There is no mention of money in this definition.
The only thing that you need to have to be
a philanthropist is generosity; the only thing
you need to have.
I believe that a philanthropist is anyone
who gives anything: time, money, experience,
skills, networks, passion, compassion in any
amount to create a better world.
In the 21st century, this definition is a
redefinition of this word.
It's a departure from what we've traditionally
thought about as a philanthropist.
In the 21st century there's actually an enormous
spectrum of what a philanthropist is.
If you volunteer at Hospice, you are a philanthropist;
if you write a fund-raising campaign or an
awareness-building campaign on Facebook, oh
I mean Google+, you are a philanthropist;
if you walk for a cure, if you donate even
ten dollars to provide vaccines for children
in developing countries, or if you have the
opportunity to donate a million dollars to
your alma mater, you are a philanthropist.
What is so important to remember about the
philanthropic spectrum is that there is no
financial hierarchy; there is no financial
hierarchy.
If a gift is significant to you, whatever
form and whatever size it takes, it will be
significant to somebody else.
[pause]
Democratizing philanthropy, I believe, is
a critical need both for our society and for
our world.
I want to call out specifically though the
power of the individual giver, the power of
individuals like every single person in this
room within the broader context of the philanthropic
sector.
This is a pie chart.
Okay that was really funny!
[laughter]
I've been gearing up for this one slide for
like three weeks.
Come on people!
I need you on my team here.
[laughter]
This is actually a pie that I made for Thanksgiving
this year which is actually a lie because
--
[laughter]
my beloved has actually banned me from the
use of both the oven and the gas stove at
home due to several kitchen fires --
[laughter]
that may or may not have been instigated by
myself.
Consequently I've developed extremely advanced
microwaving skills, but that being neither
here nor there, I digress.
Last year U.S. philanthropy totaled in excess
of $290 billion.
And you are probably going to be a little
bit surprised to hear that individuals made
up over 80 percent of this giving.
It's not the major foundations and it's not
corporations who drive American philanthropy,
it's individuals like each one of you.
Last year in fact three out of four American
households made a philanthropic gift.
[pause]
And when we look at who in fact is giving
and how much they are giving it is actually
the people who have the very least to give
who are giving the very most.
Additionally last year almost 63 million Americans
volunteered their time.
Yes?
>>Female #1: Is that the percent of their
income that they give or is that that percentage
that [unintelligible]?
>>Laura Arrillaga-Andreessen: This is the
percentage of income that on average each
give.
Sixty three million Americans volunteered
their time --
>>Female #1: [unintelligible]
[laughter]
>>Laura Arrillaga-Andreessen: I need to get
back to you on that?
But thank you for that question.
Sixty three million Americans volunteered
their time.
Those efforts totaled in excess of 8.1 billion
hours.
If you value each of those hours at what is
probably a grossly low $20 per hour, that
totals almost 170 billion dollars in value.
You can see from this data that it is in fact
ordinary Americans with extraordinary generosity
who are driving American philanthropy.
Philanthropy here in this country is actually
about the 99 percent not the one percent,
which are typically the people that we read
about.
That being said, giving at a time right now
may seem like an economic paradox.
It's a time where in any given state unemployment
is wavering between 8.5 and 13 percent.
Now more than ever we need to do more with
less.
Let me show you why.
[sound of pages turning]
[pause]
Globally 2.6 billion people are living on
less than $2 a day.
Two dollars is less than the price of a loaf
of bread at Safeway.
[pause]
Two point six billion people globally do not
have access to basic sanitation and 1.1 billion
people entered the 21st century unable to
read or write their own names.
Here in this country, nationally, one in six
Americans is living in poverty.
And poverty is being defined at just over
$22,000 a year for a family of four.
That's about the same cost as a low end Prius.
Additionally, every 26 seconds a high school
student drops out of high school here in this
country.
So during the course of our hour together,
about 125 students will drop out of high school.
High school dropouts in this country are eight
times more likely to go to prison and they
are not eligible for 90 percent of jobs.
Locally here in California one in four children
live in poverty; one in four children.
And 1.2 million students dropped out of school
in the last year.
Right up the road about five minutes up the
road in East Palo Alto, only 18 percent of
people over the age of 25 have a high school
diploma.
These are horrifying realities.
And what's equally horrifying is the fact
that we are not solving these social problems
with the way that we have been giving to date.
We have to start giving in a way that matters
more.
[pause]
A recent study, in summer of 2010, estimated
that 65 percent of all gifts by individuals
were based purely on emotion; they had no
research behind them.
When a gift is based purely on emotion you
ultimately have probably no understanding
of the impact that that gift has.
You have no understanding of the meaning of
your gift in the organizations that you are
trying to support and in the lives that you
are ultimately trying to touch.
Which gift would be more meaningful to you?
If you were giving $1,000 would it be more
meaningful for you to give that gift to end
poverty or would it be more meaningful for
you to know that because of your gift of $1,000,
ten unemployed veterans were able to participate
in a job training with the ultimate goal that
seven out of those ten had a new job within
six months?
I want you to take five seconds and just close
your eyes or look down and think about what
gifts you've given whether it's your time
or your influence or your dollars.
Which gifts have you given have been most
meaningful to you?
Just think about it for a second.
[pause]
My guess is that the ones that are most meaningful
to you are ones where you did understand the
meaning that your gift has and where you didn't
just give your dollars but you rather engaged
all of your resources: you gave your passion,
you gave your time, you gave your influence
as well, you gave your portfolio of resources
to that specific cause.
So my question, my daily question to myself
and my question today to all of you, is why
wouldn't we put the same amount of time and
effort and thought behind every single social
investment that we make as we do behind every
single for profit investment that we make?
[pause]
The problem that we have is that Americans
give a huge amount of time and money every
year, but we are not giving to our fullest
potential.
We are giving largely based on emotion and
passion when in reality we need to marry our
hearts with our minds.
We need to choose the issues that drive our
philanthropy based on our passion but we need
to choose the organizations that we fund based
on our intellect.
So how do we actualize our philanthropic potential?
How do we, as I like to say, get from 1.0
to 2.0?
Let me suggest a basic roadmap for you.
[pause]
First and foremost we need to shift our giving
from reactive to proactive.
So what does reactive giving look like?
Reactive giving is when it's the holiday season
and on our kitchen counters at home, we have
dozens of mail solicitations from very worthy
non-profit organizations which we may or may
not know anything about and we make our giving
decisions based on those mail solicitations.
Or at the end of the year when we're looking
back at everything that we've given we realize
that over half of our giving was based on
what other individuals, what our friends and
co-workers asked us to give to as opposed
to our own passion.
Reactive giving is something you feel like
you should do.
Proactive giving is when your giving is based
in your particular passion or passions.
It's when you invest not just your dollars
but also your time, your influence, your networks,
and your expertise.
Reactive giving is when you give to causes
that move you deeply and that's what enables
you to engage your intellect to have the understanding
that makes your giving not just something
that's momentarily gratifying, but something
that contributes to your life long happiness.
Proactive giving is something that you want
to do and when you want to do something as
we all know you're much more likely to do
much more of it.
We need to shift our giving from sympathetic
to strategic.
Sympathetic giving is when you give based
on, for example, a late night television ad
that shows a hungry child in need.
While your intentions are very much in the
right place you're essentially giving into
a vacuum.
You have no idea if any of the money that
you're giving will ultimately get to the child
who inspired you to give in the first place.
I would argue that it actually benefits us
greatly to extract a bit of the emotion that
drives our giving and replace it with a bit
of learning and knowledge.
When we give strategically we are actually
balancing our personal passions and we are
balancing the pull on our heart strings and
the emotional drive to give with an understanding
of core public needs and where our dollars
can be most effective; sympathetic to strategic.
And finally we need to make a shift from isolated
to collaborative.
Isolated giving is when we do our giving sitting
at home, at our desk, writing checks, mailing
them off and that constitutes our philanthropy.
Isolated giving is when we give $20 into the
collections basket at our place worship once
a week or once a month or once a year.
When you give in isolation you're actually
drastically limiting the potential impact
of your gift.
So we need to shift from isolated to collaborative.
When you choose to give collaboratively you
have a whole new world of possibilities both
for the strategic and the personal or social
benefit that your giving can have.
When you give with other people you are essentially
sharing your passion and you're sharing the
experience of expressing your generosity,
you're sharing something that makes you happy.
When you give collaboratively you also have
the potential to benefit from each other's
knowledge and learning.
So I encourage everyone to consider coming
together in a giving circle, formally or informally,
with members of your family, close friends,
members of your place of worship, co-workers,
and do research together about something you
share passion for together.
Calling local experts and understand what
are the most critical needs in your particular
issue area and then make your giving decisions
collaboratively.
Reactive to proactive; sympathetic to strategic;
and isolated to collaborative; giving 1.0
to giving 2.0.
So let me bring these core tenants to life
with a few examples.
This is a tax return like the ones that were
prepared with love and joy for free that helped
low income families save more money for back
to school clothes for their kids and healthier
meals on the table.
These tax returns are like the ones prepared
by Hector Chau.
Hector is a retiree who lives on his pension
in Western Los Angeles.
Hector does not have financial resources to
give, but what he does have to give are his
time and his expertise.
Hector was a tax accountant for 20 years.
Hector volunteers with the AARP's Tax Aid
Program which every years harnesses the time
and expertise of over 30,000 volunteers and
together they prepare tax returns, free tax
returns, for about 2.6 million families at
an average tax return prep cost of $229, that
totals about $600 million in value.
So Hector's time and expertise translates
directly into money saved for low income families.
Hector Chau is a philanthropist.
[pause]
This is a laptop like the ones that were used
to provide computer training for a young girl
in Guatemala, who through this computer training
suddenly had access to knowledge from all
around the world which she can use to pursue
her lifelong dream of becoming a teacher.
This computer training was provided with a
$40 gift by a young professional in Seattle,
Washington named Seema Bhende .
Seema is passionate about global poverty and
education.
Seema is building on generations of volunteerism
and social justice work of her parents and
her grandparents in her native country of
India.
Seema selected this gift which she made through
a funding intermediary called The Jolkona
Foundation because of the role that computer
training played in the development of her
own career.
Seema guides her giving by strategy not sympathy.
Seema is a philanthropist.
[pause]
This is a soccer ball --
like the ones that are used to teach a group
of East San Jose girls a new sport and in
turn a new confidence in themselves which
helps them thrive both in school and in life.
And across the field, their mothers are leaning
exercise in a simultaneous program.
They're also learning about nutrition and
how to cook healthier meals for their children.
Through this program, through the Bay Area
Women's Sports Network, an entire family's
well-being is improved.
And this non-profit is funded through a giving
collaborative that includes Joon Yun and Kimberly
Bazar.
Joon and Kimberly, a married couple who met
in medical school, are partners at SV2, the
Silicon Valley Social Venture Fund.
They are passionate both about women's rights
but also about philanthropic innovation.
So they choose to give not only their expertise
and their time but also their resources to
give collaboratively through SV2 and in turn
are part of a larger portfolio of 35 early
stage innovative non-profits.
And through their collaborative giving these
non-profits are able to ultimately touch many
more lives.
[pause]
These stories teach us, I believe, a powerful
lesson about how philanthropy is being democratized.
There are countless opportunities now for
us as individuals to have tangible, meaningful
impact with all of our gifts, again whatever
their size and whatever their form.
[pause]
[sound of pages turning]
So what can you do and what can you do right
now?
What can you do when you go back to your desks
and you pretend that you're working when in
reality you really want to be completing all
of your holiday shopping online?
Sitting here in Silicon Valley, you are at
the epicenter of technology and technological
innovation.
In my mind this is the most exciting place
to be in the world primarily because of how
technology is democratizing things.
Technology democratizes entire nation states
as you know, but what I find most beautiful
about technology is how it's democratizing
philanthropy.
Four ways, four of countless ways, that it's
doing this: number one, technology is providing
access to information.
Any individual who wants to be a philanthropist
can now go online and have access to the funding
portfolios and due diligence of many of the
most highly staffed, professionalized philanthropic
foundations in the world.
This is like having direct access into super
high performance money manager portfolios.
This access to information gives us the power
to shift from not just being charitable but
being strategic philanthropists.
Technology also gives us access to unique
giving opportunities.
Technology connects individuals across states,
across countries, across oceans with unique
giving opportunities and an understanding
of how your gift is directly impacting somebody
else's life in another part of the world.
So a lawyer in Kansas City or an engineer
here at Google could be directly connected
and make a gift to fund a young girl's education
in Afghanistan or make a $200 gift to provide
a prosthetic limb for a manual laborer in
Bangladesh; access to unique opportunities.
Through social networks, individuals are now
able to self-identify by the organizations
and issues that we are most passionate about.
And with five or ten minutes of your time
you can create a fund raising campaign or
an awareness building campaign or an entire
movement and with the click of a mouse send
it out to your entire social networks; powerful.
And technology also provides us access to
problem solving.
Now through creative swarms and crowd sourcing,
individuals who are otherwise completely disconnected
can collaborate online to solve some of our
world's most pressing social problems like
famine in East Africa.
These are just four simple examples of an
entire world of opportunity that technology
is creating for social change.
It's extraordinary to me that what's happening
right now at this moment is creating an entire
new platform that has potential to in turn
create an entire new culture for the philanthropic
sector; a culture of innovation.
And in my mind it is the individual donors,
who as we saw earlier, make up upwards of
80 percent of all giving, who have the responsibility
to drive this new culture of innovation.
The onus is on us to innovate in our philanthropy.
[pause]
Every single person in this room has the potential
and has the intellect and the resources to
be innovative in your giving.
And its innovation, I believe, this incessant
learning and evolution which is what will
ultimately drive each of us reaching our own
philanthropic potential.
When I think of innovation I think of three
different things: the creation of something
new; the renewal of something that already
exists; and new thinking around existing processes
and systems and problems; the creation of
something new.
For example, peer to peer giving sites like
the Jolkona Foundation and Donors Choose didn't
exist 10 or 11 years ago.
Donors Choose was created by a former teacher.
Jolkona Foundation was created by a former
Microsoft programmer.
Donors Choose in the last decade has channeled
over $100 million directly into core needs
in public education classrooms around the
country.
[pause]
Whoops, wait, we didn't mean to do that slide
quite so quickly.
[pause]
The suspense is killing you, I know.
The renewal of something that already exists.
For us as individual givers, we are constantly
coming together in groups whether it's a religious
studies group or it's a work group or you're
part of a book club or an investment club.
You have these built-in micro social networks
that you can expand to help improve your philanthropy.
You can take any of these clubs, any regular
gathering that you have with your friends
or other members of your social network and
you can create a philanthropic element to
this group that already exists.
On my website at www dot giving 2 dot com,
starting in January, I will be providing free
agendas and resources to help you take any
group and have a giving club component to
it for 2012.
And new thinking around existing problems
and systems and processes.
I challenge everyone in this room, myself
included, to make a New Year's resolution
that you're going to approach your philanthropic
giving with the same degree of seriousness
as you do your for profit investments.
With philanthropy individual lives are at
stake so why wouldn't we require an expected
return for every single investment that we
make in other people's lives and in our broader
society?
These are just three types of ways that we
innovate probably things that you do on a
regular basis in your own careers.
So these are things that are very familiar
to you.
But what's important when we go back to thinking
about the role of the individual giver, individual
givers, yourselves included, gave $235 billion
last year.
Imagine the potential of those dollars coupled
with volunteer efforts if we applied innovation
to our giving.
[pause]
So what is your Giving 2.0 going to be?
I believe that what it is we do for other
people during the course of our lifetime ultimately
defines who we are as people.
What's amazing is that every single one of
us has the ability to write the chapter of
our lives that is our giving legacy from start
to finish.
There are so many things in our lives that
we cannot control.
I cannot control the fact that I lost my mother
to cancer, but what I can control is how I
choose to celebrate her legacy through my
giving.
Giving is one of the few things in your lives
that you can completely control; you get to
make every single decision yourself.
Every person here has the potential to be
an extraordinary philanthropist, but what
you choose to do with that potential is ultimately
up to each of you.
So as you go forth and you be philanthropic
I encourage you to always remember that it's
not about what you give but rather it's about
how you give.
Thank you.
[applause]
Yeah, lunch time!
[laughter]
[laughs]
[pause]
>>Male #1: We do have a mic if you have any
questions for Laura.
[pause]
>>Female #2: Thank you so much for the presentation.
That was wonderful.
You talked a lot about accountable giving
and knowing where your dollars are going.
I'd be curious if you could provide some comments
on indices or benchmarks or types of metrics
people are able to look at when really knowing
where their dollars are going.
>>Laura Arrillaga-Andreessen: It's a fantastic
question and a question that every single
person I know in the philanthropic sector,
myself included, struggles with every single
day.
One of the trickiest parts about metrics for
giving is the fact that it is virtually impossible
to create generalized metrics even across
social issue areas because every non-profit
organization has a unique model.
What I can say is that, for you as an individual
philanthropist, if you've seen one non-profit
you've seen one non-profit and that is it.
So every non-profit you will need to do research
on yourself.
[pause]
There, so there are lots of different online
assessment tools that are, assessment organizations
that have been created.
There's GuideStar, GreatNonprofits, Philanthropedia,
GiveWell just to name a few.
I would encourage you though, for every non-profit
that you're making a gift if that gift is
significant to you, I would go and read their
annual report or even better, read their 990
report so you can see exactly how their finances
are breaking down.
Anybody who claims that having minimal overheard
is a sign of an effectively run non-profit,
I believe, does not know what they're talking
about.
There are grass roots advocacy organizations
that are going to have upwards of 80 percent
of overhead and that's gonna be fine for that
particular model.
Then there are major endowed institutions
who technically are not gonna have any expenses
every year that they have to raise through
overhead line items.
Again it's totally specific; I think specific
to the non-profit.
I think that if an organization cannot tell
you specifically what success looks like in
the short term and the intermediate term and
in the long term, that is how they know if
they're achieving their mission, then I would
not invest in that organization.
You should be able to easily answer the three
following questions: how many, how deeply,
how much?
So how many people are being touched, how
deeply are they being touched by a specific
dollar amount, that is how holistic is the
approach of this particular non-profit, and
how much does it cost them to serve each individual
life that they aspire to transform?
And finally, I think that just as leadership
plays a critically important role, actually
two final points, just as leadership plays
a critically important role in the for profit
sector, the same is absolutely true of non-profits.
So I invest in some non-profits who have extraordinary
leaders even when their particular mission
and isuary is totally outside of my area of
passion.
And then also I think it's so critically important
that every non-profit involves their ultimate
customer, that is the people who benefit from
the services, in the creation of whatever
their service model is; so involving the customers
in the products.
Winnie was just telling me that Google's holiday
gift to all the employees was the new phone
that you guys have which my beloved actually
got on Friday and is incredibly excited about.
But what's so cool about that strategic corporate
gift is Google now has the feedback loop of
individuals who would be in their customer
base in terms of what features work well,
what isn't working well, what's appealing,
what isn't appealing, what's useless, what's
useful.
The same needs to be true of how non-profits
create their products.
That was a very short answer --
[laughter]
to that simple question.
[pause]
Yes, thank you.
>>Female #3: I have a question about how you
feel disaster relief efforts fit into this
strategic planning about how you wanna give
and where to give to in times of disaster?
>>Laura Arrillaga-Andreessen: Yeah, in general,
you're speaking in general, right?
>>Female #3: Well yeah, in general but in
the past few years there've just been so many
and it feels--
>>Laura Arrillaga-Andreessen: Yeah.
>>Female #: like you're inundated with pleas
to give to different regions of the world
who all --
>>Laura Arrillaga-Andreessen: Yeah.
>>Female #3: equally have an urgent requirement.
It's very hard to understand where you make
the most impact.
>>Laura Arrillaga-Andreessen: Thank you.
So I believe I read about a week ago in the
New York Times or the Wall Street Journal
that last year alone natural disasters and
catastrophes totaled about 300, it's either
300, and I know this is a huge different,
or 390, Zack to you remember, billion dollars
in damage which is obviously in excess of
all philanthropic dollars that were given
in the United States.
I think it's really important when you're
approaching philanthropy that you think of
it in terms of a portfolio.
And I think the most significant amount of
that portfolio should be driven by your personal
passion.
That being said, I also think it's really
valuable to have a friends' fund where you
allocate a certain percentage of what you're
gonna give every year to what friends and
co-workers etcetera want you to share with
them.
But I also think it's important, if emergency
services and disaster relief is not your personal
passion, I think it's important to allow for
space in your giving portfolio for those needs
because the reality is when a natural disaster
happens or when a man-made disaster happens
or when an individual is attacked or a woman
is raped or a house burns down, that is the
greatest equalizer in our world.
Like, it does not matter who you are, where
you work, what education you have, we are
all equal in that situation.
And I, personally, believe that emergency
services and disaster relief is a critical
component of what we all should be doing;
it's actually the primary issue area that
my beloved and I fund with our philanthropy,
primarily because it's the single most underfunded
area in medicine, in institutional medicine.
But I always encourage everyone to participate,
but do so only through pre-vetted institutions.
So if you choose to give to the Red Cross
do so with full awareness of the fact that
the Red Cross when it's raising money for
any given disaster will be keeping a portion
of that money so that it has immediate funds
that can get right into the hands of the people
that need them the most when the next disaster
happens.
Another great way to meet core community needs
and critical needs through a very secure --
[pause]
pre-vetted type of organization is giving
through local community foundations.
So when Hurricane Katrina happened or --
[pause]
when 9/11 happened it was the United Way of
New York City and the New York Community Trust
that came together and created the September
11th Fund.
And that ultimately was one of the most, was
probably the most successful effort that met
not only short term but also immediate term
needs for that particular crisis and did so
in a way that broadly defined who the victims
were.
[pause]
>>Female #4: Hi --
>>Laura Arrillaga-Andreessen: Hi.
>>Female #4: thanks so much for being here.
My question is about the idea of program funding
versus unrestricted funding.
And I know nowadays obviously program funding
is really sexy, everyone wants to give to
programs because you can see your direct impact,
you can see the people that you're helping,
you're buying supplies, blankets whatever,
but that the reality of many non-profits is
that the kind of funding they really need
is unrestricted funding for their general
operating budget.
What's your, what kind of advice do you give
to donors to get them to understand the importance
of that?
>>Laura Arrillaga-Andreessen: That's one of
my very --
>>Female #4: Versus like seeding --
>>Laura Arrillaga-Andreessen: favorite topics.
One of my personal goals is to make general
operating grants even sexier than program
grants, because program funds are the single
easiest funds for any non-profit to raise
primarily because if you do a bit of research
you can connect directly with a teen, a troubled
at risk youth, who you're helping to get an
education or a family that you're helping
through providing transitional housing to
or a specific number of individuals who are
getting treatment for a particular disease.
But in reality none of those programs would
even exist if organizations did not have the
general operating funds that provides the
core infrastructure for all of their service
provisions.
At SV2, the Silicon Valley Social Venture
Fund, we actually only give organizational
capacity building grants and we do that primarily
because those are the single hardest funds
to raise.
The only type of grants that my husband and
I give through all of our philanthropy, and
same with my family's philanthropy, are general
operating grants.
So I would encourage you to understand the
impact that a non-profit has, but don't impose
your personal needs or ego or idea of what
the organization needs on that organization;
make an investment in the leadership team
and let them allocate those funds.
[pause]
>>Male #2: Hi.
>>Laura Arrillaga-Andreessen: Hi.
>>Male #2: My name is Sebastian and I work
in a team that actually seeks to provide non-profits
with AdWords advertising so I'm particularly
inspired in a way I see us trying to connect
NGOs with those millions of givers out there
so thank you for the talk.
It's great to see that you're educating these
givers and you're getting much more of them
onto giving.
What I wanted to ask and something that I
struggle is to in trying to get a more holistic
picture of the whole non-profit sector, so
what are the ways I mean understanding the
different players, different types of NGOs,
umbrella orgs?
And you touch upon some of that from a particular
angle in your book, but are there any courses
out there or here in the area that we can
take to keep furthering our understanding
of the non-profit sector?
>>Laura Arrillaga-Andreessen: Ahh --
>>Male #2: Any suggestions?
>>Laura Arrillaga-Andreessen: That's such
a fabulous question.
[pause]
You know what I would love to do is if you
wanna give me your card and Winnie, perhaps,
we can work with you in this.
Why don't I and my team, my two former star
students, Stacy Walder from the Business School
and Zack D'Angelo from my undergraduate class,
why don't you give us a couple weeks and we'll
put together like a big bibliography of resources
that you can tap into to help further your
work.
>>Male #2: That'd be amazing.
>>Laura Arrillaga-Andreessen: Okay, great.
>>Male #2: Thank you very much.
>>Laura Arrillaga-Andreessen: Sure.
Thank you all so much.
[applause]